so you want to make your British crime
film well you came to the right place
the easiest and most efficient way to go
about doing this is to be a British
person but since most of you won't be
able to accomplish that here are some
other ways to pull it off first off you
need a catchy title not that many people
watch these films so it's very important
to make the title as unique as possible
with that said here are the only three
options you have for creating the name
of your film
number one title the film the location
you are shooting if you're shooting your
film in Bruges call your film in Bruges
if your characters are running from
London to Brighton call it London to
Brighton actually you don't even have to
add in words such as in in - if you
don't want to open up Google Maps in the
name of where you are at that moment
should pop up
copy and paste it onto a poster and you
have yourself a title I'm pretty sure
that's what they did for down Terrace in
Brighton wrong number to title your film
the lead character's name why bother
taking the time to figure out where you
are when you're leading man's name is
badass who wouldn't want to go see a
movie called Harry Brown or Bronson or
the craves number three if neither one
of the preceding option sounds alluring
you can always randomly select one
obscure word to be the title of your
masterpiece Google search random word
generator and you'll come up with titles
like revolver piggy scum snatch and
blitz and when it comes to casting you
have many choices Jason Statham Michael
Caine Colin Farrell or Vinnie Jones to
name a few but really you should go with
Jason Statham I mean come on he's Jason
Statham when writing your characters you
need to make sure they all have
interesting nicknames such as clocking
soap pretty crazy lardy vikon buzz the
blight the dope take a great multi
purchase also there should probably be a
guy named Perry all right let me go hey
I need your help everything right
Carrie Carrie lastly they all need to
wear suits lots and lots of suits well
you better get right now the plot of
your film should be very complicated I
don't mean like oh wow that was
interesting complicated I mean like
mentioning 15 different characters names
at the beginning and expecting people to
remember every single one of the names
for the entirety of the film complicated
how do you introduce your seedy
characters in the world they're in
voiceover of course what other option is
there wash the residue off my hands in
the bathroom of a Burger King and walked
home to await instructions Vikon could
see there is days of selling moody goods
on street corners are numbered I'm a
businessman whose commodity happens to
be cocaine one thing I could never stand
was to see a filthy dirty old drunky
it's rumored that brick top's favorite
means of dispatch or else a stun gun oh
yeah bloody hell people have come to
expect the dialogue and British crime
films to be witty in entertaining if you
can't write whittier entertaining
dialogue have an act with an
unintelligibly thick accent deliver the
lines the Smith uses more Zosia see then
oldest and Aristotle the most people
today in the nucleus up two legs
thanks but yeah that's that right you
know it looks great on camera a British
person's head exploded whether the head
is being shot or smashed the blunt
object is really up to you show himself
once you finish the film
you need a poster although it is not
required it will significantly help to
sell your film if you have a gun on the
poster and finally if everything fails
you can't cast Jason Statham you can't
afford voice over time in a studio you
can't write witty dialogue you can't
have someone pose with a gun for your
poster and you can't even make someone's
head explode don't worry there's still
hope the single most important thing you
need to remember we're making a British
crime film is that you need to include a
ton of f-bombs Oh get the go get the
King coat you get the King Kong are you
fuckin you should make it your personal
mission to include as many versions of
the word in your film as possible it's
an anonymous he organized out of it King
objet I'm talking up in the hundreds
possibly the thousands if you can manage
it I'll tell you all fucking up and you
tell me girl you tell me what fucking
happened give me a fucking knock like
you're fucking what are you fucking
psycho well no I can problem in the
plane you can play with five the plane
was alright and plane was perfect at you
you're a problem got a problem
not this fucking time no not this
fucking time no do I know you I know you
I know you why you might be looking
right and that's in it
follow these concern Boleyn structures
and your can be on your way to making
your own in British crime film
done